bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
un seul être vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé pascal praud n'est pas là il
reviendra très rapidement pense fort à
lui bien évidemment
allô allô
de philippe poutou bonjour est arrivé
mouvement votre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
je vous appelle car nous allons vivre
dimanche un jour historique vous avez
l'avenir de la preuve entre vos mains
semblent
liberté liberté
c'est
bercy avec moi choisissez la liberté
[Rires]
jeu set et fin jo-wilfried tsonga a
annoncé hier sur ces réseaux sociaux
mettre un terme à sa carrière dans une
vidéo sous forme d'interview en famille
et en chaussettes s'il vous plaît le
français qui aura 37 ans la semaine
prochaine a expliqué la principale
raison de son retrait des courts je
pense à feu plusieurs années où tous les
jours dans la journée
[Musique]
comme quoi le kinder bueno
jo wilfried tsonga c'est derrière mais
c'est surtout kinda c'est dur quand même
de réduire jo wilfried tsonga haas alors
que c'est un des plus grand tennisman
français
magnifique magnifique mais pas une
carrière d'acteur
on abandonne la télé on fait de la
fiction maintenant ah non mais là je
n'abandonne rien c'est à dire que tout
le monde a mon numéro et se soigne pas
donc on va pas se leurrer au bout d'un
moment vous voulez qu'on donne je
m'étais donnée qui m'était donné trois
ans tu vois il ya deux ans et demi chez
pascale clark donc je pense que c'est
bon s'ils ont besoin de moi et ça me
trouver mais je voudrais tracteur parce
qu'en fait c'est un vieux rêve je tiens
encore à peu près deux bouts j'ai dit
que je ne voulais jamais faire jouer des
gens qui n'étaient pas des acteurs au il
avait déjà tourné dans un film oui voilà
ah oui voilà mais on va dire que oui je
me suis pas trouvé
je me suis pas trouvé vous n'êtes pas le
guest de ce film vous n'êtes pas les
stars de noms sur les personnages autour
bien sûr bref donc il avait déjà tourné
dans un film je me dis qu après tout
j'ai ouvert des créneaux j'ai ouvert les
après midi j'ai ouvert la partie de
soirée j'ai été le premier talk-show à
19h au monde semble vous raviser oh la
la moi je venais vous voir à coucou
c'est nous je me suis notamment la
maison d'arrêt deux avec dustin hoffman
et je regardais ce mec est incroyable je
m en fac je pense oui les gens ça oui
mais coucou c'était une grosse récré je
pense que quand on est passé en plus
entre les mains parce qu'en fait elle a
l'art de rien mais elle voit très vite l
ère de la disney
mais non passif est incroyable non mais
chante un super pardon anglais vous vous
êtes discrète
allez à gauche à droite à gauche
bonjour y gouverne t coup nous avons à
nice et à blida et experts et qu
évidemment
beaucoup
mon point fort je pense que c'est mon
côté fashion et jeunes parce que je suis
dans la tendance contraire - des
concurrentes moi ça veut dire quoi ça
c'est tout et vieille peau oui c'est ça
d'accord motif
avoir par rapport à la vieille pauvres
on va voir pour qui elle se prend elle
c'est une plaisanterie ou quoi moi un à
titre personnel je respecte les gens pas
bien vu avec des fleurs je suis une
femme très gentille très beau diable
avec beaucoup de classe excusez moi je
demande de m'excuser
effectivement vous êtes la classe
incarnée